patriots receiver julian edelman ended
the year with a super bowl mvp trophy he
began the season with a four-game ped
suspension and peter king of football
morning in america recently met with
edelman interviewed him about a variety
of things but on one specific topic
edelman wouldn't talk he had nothing to
say about that ped violation and he
cited league rules that prohibit him
from talking
that's just flat out incorrect the
league rule is in place to prevent
others from breaching edelman's
confidentiality rights but they are his
rights if he chooses to waive those
privacy rights and talk about why he was
suspended what he did that prompted a
violation whatever he wants to talk
about he's allowed to do it now there's
one caveat if he says something's
factually incorrect the nfl can come in
and say he has said something that's
factually incorrect here is the truth
but as long as he's residing within the
confines of the truth he can say
anything he wants to say some have
suggested that maybe he was simply told
by the patriots not to talk about it and
instead of saying the patriots have told
me not to talk about it he's opting to
say the league rules prevent him from
talking about it which again is
incorrect choosing to tell something
other than the truth over disclosing the
reality if this theory is accurate that
the patriots have told edelman to zip it
it wouldn't be the first time the
patriots tell a player or anyone else
connected to the team to zip it it
really wouldn't be a surprise because
from the patriots perspective
they'd just as soon not have anyone who
was caught cheating go down that rabbit
hole as to why and where and how or talk
about it in any way
because that dredges up all sorts of bad
memories from the past and gives people
ammunition to point at the patriots and
say see they don't win all those games
because they're better than everyone
they win all those games because they're
doing something they shouldn't do never
mind the fact that most teams have guys
who get suspended for ped violations
when it comes to the patriots that's a
sore subject and maybe the wisdom in all
of this even though edelman isn't
telling the truth about the league rules
the wisdom is he's ended the discussion
ended the conversation and ended any
speculation about why it is that he
ended up being suspended for violating
the ped policy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports